legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon the possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it stop ah hello just
wanted you to know this has been
mislabeled
[Music]
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest but
also the most thrilling heads up come a
Duke
look out
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world
we're headed upriver lagrimas de cristal
for mr. huron travel come on
got a good time my brother looking for
passage upriver please go away
I have a lot of money ever you believe
in legends if you believe in curses -
you're gonna beg minutes are back no I
look forward to disappointing you ten
thousand to bring you there alive Dead
is 15,000 why should I pay me dead
dad I'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady here we go
oh sorry Frank sorry strong for me
I dunno swim you book the river cruise
and you can't swim the price just went
out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]